Gina carama was a pretty famous mixed
martial artist and she became an actress
who became even more successful she
appeared in films like Deadpool and Fast
and Furious for a while she was on the
Disney show the Mandalorian but then her
career hit a brick wall why well she was
fired because she had heterodox opinions
on face masks and the 2020 election
she wasn't particularly political or
certainly not a partisan but they
crushed her for it but she's unbowed we
sat down with her for a brand new
episode of Tucker Carlson today
pretty amazing interview here is Gina
Chrono explaining how she responded when
Disney told her she had to give her
pronouns
[Music]
when I wouldn't hashtag trans rights and
I wouldn't put my pronouns in like they
kept on it pressuring and finally I just
said I'm not I'm not doing this you know
like I'm not like what are the pronouns
I didn't even know what people were
talking about I was just not clued in to
the pronouns thing which apparently been
that's been happening for like like
seven eight years now right it's been
happening but no one has ever explained
nobody's purpose what I mean I didn't
know you're just supposed to know yeah
and if you don't know you're a bigot
yeah well then I put beep bop boop in my
beep boop yeah so that if I'm
Translating that just means middle
finger to you right well that just meant
I can put anything I want in my bio I
can do whatever I want that's that's all
that was because you thought it was a
free country yeah because I thought it
was a yes I was speaking out about
lockdowns Mass vaccinations and
pronouns way before anybody was even
like saying a word about it and so I was
a little bit ahead I'm sure if I would
have done that now it would have been a
big deal but because I was talking about
this when nobody else was talking about
it especially nobody else in my industry
it was like
um Luca's film called me and they were
like okay we're gonna need you to get
um go on a zoom call with 45 of our you
know lgbtq you know community and we
have to get you on the phone with these
people we need to watch we need to have
you watch all these trans
um these movies about the trans lives
um documentaries and and I was like okay
I'll watch your documentaries and I'll
talk to your people
um but I'm not going to get on a zoom
call with 45 different people who can
have their phones out and videotaping me
and I feel like that's extremely abusive
okay
we just become fascinated in the last
two years by bravery and where it
emerges in people you would never expect
it to emerge in that's a brave woman and
a really interesting conversation it's a
Tucker Carlson today tomorrow 7 A.M on
Fox Nation
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight